I'm gonna give a talk about a proposal
that I made to Stephen Wolfram quite a
while ago this just recently bubbled up
in the priorities because of our
interest in 3d printing and this is an
audience participation talk I'm going to
give a brief presentation and then the
interesting part is going to come from
you I hope so let me just jump to my
last slides you can prepare for it so
what I'm talking about this proposal I'd
like you to keep these questions in mine
what could you imagine using a designs
based site for can you imagine any
interesting design spaces you might want
to explore and have you ever seen a
design Speights ice design space site
like this before so here's a very simple
manipulate based on a very simple idea I
you have these rounded stars so it's
just essentially a circle whose radius
is modulated by sign and I've given
myself controls for the number of points
on the star and the depth of the
indentations in the star of course this
is this shape is drawn using a straight
line segment approximation if you crank
the resolution down eventually you start
seeing the the line segments and you get
this interaction between the number of
points on the stars and the resolution
that you're drawing it with so you get
these inks flat kinds of figures and
depending on how these the parameters
interact you can get a large variety of
different kinds of things splats so now
you take one of these figures and you
just stack it up with ever smaller
copies of itself alternately black and
white and if you continue that then you
start getting these kinds of effects and
now if I add just a tiny bit of
displacement to each copy then you also
start getting some let me crank the
points down just a little bit you're
also getting start getting some
three-dimensional quality and you can
also add some rotation two successive
copies
and then you start getting a really wide
variety of different kinds of graphic
effects and so as I scrub through here
there's a really diverse variety of
graphic effects you can get from this
simple idea and this is a design space
right it's a family of designs not a
particular dot design but a family of
designs and the conceptually the
addresses of the designs within the
design space are given by the settings
of the controls so and because of the
way the controls interact you get this
complexity it is absolutely impossible
to predict and I can show you the code I
can show you the values of the
parameters there's no way you're going
to know what this is going to look like
right so I would love to have a bot that
goes out into this design space and
finds interesting forms for me but of
course what's interesting depends on
details of the human visual system and
perception and psychology and lots of
stuff and until we can model those
things somehow we're not going to have
automatic agents that can go out and
find these things so the only way to
find the interesting things in this
design space is to go out and explore it
for people to go out and explore and
that was a genesis of the idea that i
presented to stephen which was what if
we had a website where people could
submit design spaces and other people
could come and explore them and if we
could bring the social aspect into the
exploration of design spaces then
interesting design spaces might get
explored new phenomena interesting
phenomena might be discovered and people
might be encouraged to create even more
interesting design spaces for others to
explore so this is the proposal that I
that I gave to Steven so this site might
be called the Wolfram design space this
just explains what a design space is as
I just explained to you and I think the
Wolfram language is particularly good at
describing design spaces because is
very high level it's very easy to create
the interfaces you need to do the
exploration and it has such a breadth of
functionality that you can describe a
large variety of phenomena and I really
don't know any other language it would
be so appropriate for describing design
spaces as a Wolfram language so as I
explained these spaces can be just
unimaginably vast you know a few
parameters and you've got a huge
combinatorial explosion but they can
contain very interesting particular
designs and the only way to find out
what's in there is to go out and explore
them so you got to have people exploring
them so my proposal was that well from
research should create this website
called the Wolfram design space and we
would organize design spaces that are
charted and mapped and that this would
serve as an ongoing source of ideas or
material or just cool cool visuals
whatever so there would be four ways to
participate submitting exploring rating
and browsing so of course the first step
would be for people to submit design
spaces and really a lot of them are just
very much like demonstrations of things
that are submitted to demonstrations but
this site would bring us some additional
support to this exploration aspect and
then you could come to the site Explorer
spaces that other people is submitted
and plant flags at interesting locations
in the design space so that way we start
to map out what these designs places
look like and where the interesting
things in them are and then you could
also come and look at the things that
people have found and like them or not
so that you start to get a feeling for
what the terrain looks like not only
where the interesting things are but how
interesting they are
and then finally you might come to the
to the site just to see what's there the
interesting stuff that's there just to
get inspiration you might want to take
me to the site to elaborate to make a
logo for example or you might come to
the site and this was the the motivation
for bringing this up again the site
might be a repository for parametric 3d
designs so you might come there to
customize a design and 3d printed so for
the design world I think this would
provide several things that provides an
infrastructure for this idea of social
exploration of design spaces it promotes
the idea of a design space is a thing to
be designed in itself and I'll get to
that a little more later it promotes the
concept of crowd-sourced social
exploration design space creating
communities of people that are exploring
these things Anakin serve as a resource
for just interesting material I think we
should be doing this because we have the
technology to do it right primarily the
Wolfram language and we have the
experience to do it right because we've
been collecting experience with CDF with
Wolfram community with demonstrations
Wolfram cloud all these aspects are
really important and I think this is
uncolonized internet territory I don't
know of any space of any sites that
attempt to to support this ok so my
interest is in primarily graphic design
and 3d sculptural design and
particularly in design spaces that are
intentionally designed to to be
surprising to be unpredictable to have
interesting things out there defined
when you're going to explore them but
there are many different varieties
possible varieties of design spaces both
in the domain of things that are in the
design space and the way the design
space is constructed for what purpose so
let me just go through some examples
spaces of dimensioned structures is a
possibility so in contrast of the design
space that I described before if I tell
you the dimensions of the phone case you
can probably imagine what
look like right it's not it's not a huge
leap of imagination but there's still a
role for social exploration here because
you can crowdsource having people you
know put on all the right dimensions for
all the different kinds of phones there
are and you know planning flag this is
the iphone case this is the galaxy case
whatever and I think architecture might
be an interesting application area
especially in massing studies generative
architecture which is a hot topic in
some circles logos would be an
interesting application in fact I made a
demonstration which a group at the
University it was a demonstration for
exploring a particular kind of logo
family of logos and a group at the
University of Pennsylvania made us a
swoosh logo for their group with it I
think that kind of thing can be
interesting I could be parametric
clipart like this heart shape
or art art pardon oh really okay one of
Abby's students did this yeah so this is
make your own Rothko it's kind of like
josef albers color study explorations or
this sort of a part passarelli like like
thing there's no reason to the objects
in the design space cannot contain a
time parameter so you could explore
design spaces of animations like this
one this is one a clayton shank Wyler's
endless loop gif animations which i
modified to it was just a single
parameters you can explore different
variations on that and then similarly by
incorporating time for example wait
cursor animations right you can just
have this thing running and explore
various graphical variations on that
also with the time dimension sound is a
very rich can be very rich design spaces
and plug in here so this is a very
simple F analysis but even they just
start new parameters as a very large
range of different effects add a couple
of more controls and you've got a huge
space of interesting sounds to explore
and along the same lines music write
melodies harmonies rhythms whatever so
one reason that people might be inclined
in to visit a site like this would be to
get material outputs and of course there
are sites like zazzle and sculpt do and
shape ways and so forth you can with
dazzle you can print your graphic design
on anything you think of shirts pillows
bugs flip-flops whatever of course 3d
printing or laser cutting whatever so we
would so I anticipate we would have a
connection depending on the type of the
output to all these printing their
reproduction services
so big question for me is if we were to
do this what would give us staying power
what would make it an active community
what would draw people in what would
keep people coming and I think that it
would be the social aspect so if I
submit a design space I'm going to be
interested in what people find in the
design space and and what designs they
find interesting if I find something
interesting in a design space i'm going
to be interested in what other people
find this interesting or i might be it
you know i might see a related design
space that i want to implement or out
there for the field to explore so so my
hope is if we were to do this it would
become a vibrant community of people
creating design spaces exploring design
spaces and finding interesting stuff so
that brings me to my final slide again
so I'd like to hear from you if you have
any ideas about what you could imagine
using a design space site for can you
imagine any interesting design spaces
you might like to explore and have you
ever seen anything like this elsewhere
you